This story is absolutely fascinating and there's
so much that we can discuss, but we should really
kind of start with with a clip and one of the
really kind of lightweight when it comes to,
you know, intellectually one of the really
lightweight Republican senators out there is a
guy named Ron Johnson. He represents Wisconsin and
he's gone completely off the deep end in the past,
for example, during a recent congressional hearing
about the January 6th riots. He suggested that the
insurrectionists weren't really Trump supporters,
but it was some combination of provocateurs
and fake Trump supporters. And we're going to
get to that because it exposes his obvious lies
in a moment. But I want to start with a clip
of Ron Johnson recently going on the Joe Pags
radio show. I don't know if this is an
online show or like a broadcast radio,
but he went on this show and he
said he didn't feel threatened.
Ron Johnson didn't feel threatened during
the January 6th riots. Now, you might say,
well, why why didn't he feel threatened if if they
were, you know, provocateurs and antifa or whoever
that should be threatening to him as a Republican,
right? Well, no. He says he didn't feel threatened
because the rioters were pro Trump people who love
the country. But had they been Black Lives Matter,
had they been antifa, he might have
been afraid to take a look at this clip.
Just white supremacists, they don't really believe
that, but they know there's a percentage of those
that they're telling that that will believe it.
That's really the game, right? I mean, there's
no way people you're going to work with every day
really think that you and I are white supremacists
because we believe in conservative values, right?
No, no. Let's face I'm also criticized because
I've made the comment that on January six, I
never felt threatened because I didn't and mainly
because I knew that even though those thousands
of people there were marching to the Capitol,
we're trying to pressure people like me to vote
the way they want me to vote. I knew those are
people that love this country, that truly respect
law enforcement, would never do anything to break
a law. And so I wasn't certain. Now, had the
tables been turning, Joe, this could mean trouble
had the tables been turned and President Trump
won the election and those were tens of thousands
of Black Lives Matter and TIFA protesters,
I might have been a little concerned. Wow.
That's that's a big statement, but it's a
true statement. We see the recent history.
Well, and let's face it, you know, people can
board up their storefronts in metropolitan areas
in case Joe Biden won. And you take a look at
what's happening in Minneapolis, the trial.
So there are just a ton of things there to talk
about. Now, first of all, it's hard to hear him
say that and not get the sense that he sort of
means I wasn't scared because the protesters
were white, which, of course, they were almost
exclusively white. If it had been black people
under the banner of Black Lives Matter
or Antifa, then I would have been scared.
He does stop just short of saying that. So I'm
sort of inferring. I admit I'm speculating. It
has that feeling. He doesn't actually say
it. So let's not focus too much on that.
The part that's hilarious is that in this
interview, Ron Johnson says, I wasn't scared
because the protesters were Trump people who love
the country and wanted the election overturned.
They're on his side, so to speak. But during
the recent congressional testimony, he used
his question and answer time to suggest that they
were not really Trump supporters on January 6th,
but they were fake Trump supporters. This was
just a couple of weeks ago. Remember this clip?
Also, the people I were who passed me along
Constitution Avenue, some are indignant
and contemptuous of Congress, but not one
appeared angry or incited to riot. Many of
the marchers were families with small children.
Many were elderly, overweight or just plain tired
or frail traits not typically attributed to the
riot prone. Many were propolis shirts or carried
propolis black and blue flags. Although the crowd
represented a broad cross-section of Americans,
mostly working class by their appearance and
manner of speech. Some people stood out. A very
few didn't share the jovial, friendly, earnest
demeanor of the great majority. Some obviously
didn't fit in. And he describes four different
types of people plainclothes militants, agents,
provocateurs, fake Trump protesters and then
disciplined uniformed column of taxers. I think
these are the people that probably planned this.
So were you noticing the absurdity of this
in February during the hearings about Trump
supporters who did the riots? Ron Johnson floats
the idea. They weren't really Trump supporters.
They were fake Trump supporters. They were
provocateurs. But now he's asked in an interview,
did you feel threatened? He says, why would I
feel threatened? These are just people who love
America. And they wanted me to vote a certain way.
They wanted me to object to the electoral count.
Wait a second. Run. Two weeks ago, you said they
weren't real Trump supporters. Now you say they
are. And that's why you didn't feel threatened.
How can both possibly be true? Which one does
he. Truly believe I think we know which one,
I think he believes they were Trump supporters
and he was super comfortable with the fascist
authoritarian rioters who were seeking to overturn
the election because they're on his side. Had they
been antifascist protesters, he would have been
very, very scared. And you tell me whether you
think that that's ideology based or race based
or whatever the case may be. A disgusting guy
never fails to impress that upon me. And this is
just one example of I actually believe there's two
layers to this. When elected officials like this
guy talk about they might have been fake Trump
supporters, I don't think any of them believe
it when they talk about Antifa was spotted or
the no real trace, the no true Scotsman fallacy,
no real Trump supporter would riot. Therefore,
anyone rioting could not have been a Trump
supporter. I don't think the elected officials
believe it for a second, but unfortunately,
a lot of their constituents do. And I've seen
some people I went to high school with. I went
to a very diverse high school ideologically,
so to speak, people I went to high school with.
I've seen genuinely posting on Facebook that
they believe it was antifa in disguise. They don't
believe that they were actual Trump supporters,
that it was antifa in disguise that got all
the Trump flags and the Trump hats and first
went to the rally and also posted on Facebook for
weeks that they were going to be there and their
entire Facebook persona was staged to look like
some people really fell for this obviously false
notion. So when Ron Johnson floated it two weeks
ago, three weeks ago, I didn't really believe he
believed it. Now it becomes very clear and truly
just a bottom feeder, disgusting, disgusting guy.